[Musique]
dis papa quand c'est qui passe le
marchand de cou j'en voudrai dans mes
godasses à la place des joujous avec mes
copines en classe on comprend pas tout
pourquoi les gros dégueulasses font du
mal partout pourquoi les enfants de
bfast et tous les ghetto quand il
balance un caillass on leur fait la peau
je croyais que David et Goliath ça
marchait encore que les plus petits
pouvaient se débattre sans être les plus
morts dit papa quand c'est qui passe le
marchand de liberté il en a oublié un
max en sens sa tourné pourquoi des mes
trêent de faim pendant qu'on est étouffe
V té comme des crétins sous des tonnes
de
bouffes dis papa quand c'est qui passe
le marchand de tendresse s'il est sur le
trottoir d'en face DIY qui traverse je
peux lui enfiler un peu pour ceux qu'en
ont besoin j'en ai reçu tellement mon
vieux que je veux en donner tout plein
je veux partager mon McDo avec ceux qui
ont faim je peux donner de l'amour bien
chaud à ceux qu'ont plus rien est-ce que
c'est ça tre co ou être un vrai chrétien
moi je me fous de tous ces mots je peux
être un vrai humain il papa tous ces
discours me font mal aux oreilles même
ceux qui sont plein d'amour c'est qui
KFF pareill ça me fait comme des trous
dans la tête ça me volue la vie et tout
ça fait que je vois sur ma planète des
partout
papa quand c'est qui passe le marchand
de cailloux j'en voudrais dans mesgolass
à la place des joujou mais sur ta
guitare j'enetterai aussi si tu te seres
de moi trouillard pour chanter tes
conneries sur ta guitare j'it aussi si
tu te faire de moi trouillard pour
chanter tes conneries
[Musique]